I used to have nothing then I got this job
this family but nothing lasts forever
I heard you had to leave in a hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do I've lived a
lot of lives but I'm done running from
my past
I know you're out there I know you know
I'm out here so we gonna talk like
grown-ups is that what we are
it's good to see sis, what brings you
home.
we have unfinished business we have to
go back to where it all started.
lucky us
one thing's for sure
it's gonna be a hell of a reunion
still fits family back together again
you got fat
welcome back everyone its charlie happy
late-night video they posted this at
midnight so I'm making this super late
but all kinds of Easter eggs in this
this is a longer version of the footage
that they showed off at d23 so we'll
break it down we're doing a giveaway for
that giant infinity Saga box set with
all the Marvel movies all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the trailer on
the video I know you have all kinds of
questions about what's going on with
Sheriff hopper dressed like the Russian
Captain America he's playing Red
Guardian he literally is the Russian
version of Captain America during the
Cold War through espionage the Russians
tried to steal a version of the Super
Soldier serum and then adapted for their
own program he is the product of that
all kinds of questions about Thunderbolt
Ross and possible Thunderbolts set up in
future movies or future TV shows with
the new version of Black Widow yelena
Belova played by Florence Pugh so the
beginning of the trailer they start with
her voice over a cut with shots of
Budapest that's right we're going to
Budapest finally that's the freedom
Monument just to let you know that you
are in Budapest when this is happening
in the present day of the movie which is
taking place in the past what's this we
just did all this time travel during
Avengers endgame the voice-over dialogue
that she has at the beginning of this
has literally taken from her endgame
dialogue first I had nothing then I had
this family during that movie she was
referring to the Avengers as her family
but in this movie taking place during
the past you meet her old family that
she used to be with when she was still
part of the Black Widow program and this
trailer is crawling with a bunch of
black widows when she's staring into the
mirror here in this bathroom this is
probably right after she's gone on the
run right after Captain America Civil
War like in the beginning of the trailer
Thunderbolt Ross has that voice over
dialogue where he's talking to her
saying I heard you had to leave in a
hurry where are you going and she talks
about not running from her past anymore
I've done this many times before she's
thumbing through all the different IDs
all this present-day stuff with her and
Budapest in these scenes with her with
Yelena Belova version of Black Widow
that's taking place right after Captain
America Civil War before Avengers
infinity war she's on the run for a
couple different reasons one of them
being that she's a fugitive and they
actually want to arrest her on sight if
she's spotted by the Americans but the
Black Widow program in the Red Room also
probably wants to get rid of her too
because she's trying to bring that down
you kind of get a sense for the
narrative in the
she's trying to save her sisters her
family by getting rid of the red-room
she's tired of running from her past her
past literally running to chase her down
through the Red Room soldiers here this
is just part of that flashback in the
nightmare that she got from a Scarlet
Witch during Avengers age of Ultron this
is her origin story when she was going
through the Red Room program you can
kind of chart how old she is just based
on the haircut that she has then as she
continues that voiceover dialog from
Avengers end game they flashed to the
first Avengers movie with the short
haircut her talking to Hawkeye they
referenced Budapest's during that movie
obviously you see several shots of
budapest and her running around in
budapest during the trailer big theory
that Hawkeye is going to show up during the
movie at some point and we see
taskmaster using a very large bow which
makes you think instantly of Hawkeye not
that Hawkeye is taskmaster then there's
a whole bunch of Winter Soldier footage
the soundtrack during this with the big
music drops where that screeching sound
sounds like it's right out of Winter
Soldier so the soundtrack will probably
be a little bit like winter soldiers
soundtrack the nothing lasts forever
lion is also just a reference to the
idea that she's still dead in
present-day
Scarlett Johansson has been very clear
that her version of Natasha Black Widow
is dead after avengers endgame this is
all taking place during the past even
though there might be a time jump in a
post-credits scene in present-day with
another version of Black Widow like
Jelena Belova most of these trailer
scenes only take place in a couple
different areas one is Budapest
the other is Siberia where the actual
Red Room program is where you see her
trying to blow everything up then the
separate location nearby where they're
at that cabin having that family moment
together fun fact - I know everybody's
wondering if Winter Soldier is going to
have a cameo during this Winter Soldier
was actually controlled by Hydra people
and Hydra was not running the Red Room
so even though both of them were working
within the Soviet Union in Russia
technically they're on slightly
different teams all this footage here is
just connected to this other shot here
from later in the trailer they kind of
break it up where you see her in her old
uniform pre Avengers with a special
gauntlets it's more of a comic book II
Black Widow looking suit this just seems
like this version of Thunderbolt Ross
who actually seems like he's got that
crazy D aging technology that they did
for ant-man and the wasp to William Hurt
doesn't look that old and present-day so
I don't know why there D aging him this
much but maybe this was just meant to be
for she joined the Avengers so it's
early 2000s era once she finishes her
conversation with Thunderbolt Ross about
not running from her past anymore living
a lot of different lives she seeks out
Yelena Belova also in Budapest in this
building walking up the staircase all
this footage is from the d23 trailer
they showed off with her walking down
the hallway with her gun pointed then
having that funny gunslinger standoff
moment and because they both came up in
the Red Room programmes they know all
the same moves as each other they're so
evenly matched that they eventually just
have to give up and just treat each
other like actual sisters although
sisters do fight a lot that's kind of
the joke of this scene here is that they
treat each other like real sisters if
you're not a big black widow comic book
reader Yelena Belova was actually
trained to take down Natasha
Black Widow and take the mantle from her
so when she debuted in the comics they
were originally enemies but eventually
became friends and started working
together with each other their story
within the MCU is obviously a little bit
different but they always changed the
comics a little bit for the movies their
fight scene is great they have the fight
coordinator from John wick working on
this movie so it's going to feel a lot like
John wick fights but also they're using
the Winter Soldier soundtrack for some
of these sound cues I think they're
going to go for a lot of Winter Soldier
type action in the movie just because
that movie did hand-to-hand combat so
well they also kind of used the camera
in this fight to pan around the room and
show you that Yelena Belova also has
been on the run too you see all these
plans in these maps so it sounds like
she's having a lot of the same problems
as Natasha and that's why they're slowly
coming back together to be this family
to handle the problem as a family they
go on the run together then you get a
lot of scenes with taskmaster chasing
them down through the city so I think
even though it comes later in the
trailer when taskmaster is in this urban
assault vehicle and that has the giant
Hawkeye looking bow that he pulls out
that's him chasing after them on the
motorcycle this is the Black Widow
that's chasing after them that it looks
like she's either trying to save from
falling might be Melina Bostic off
Rachel Wise's character who's also a
former Black Widow from the Red Room but
it's kind of blurry so it could be one
of the other black widows from
present-day that it seems like they're
also training here with a slightly
different looking uniforms like the
program is still going on in present day
just like Winter Soldier would still be
operating out of Siberia in Hydra in
present day if they hadn't rescued him
she tells Yelena Belova that we have to
go back to where
started to where they were trained as
black widows this might be a flashback
they just want to apply the way they cut
this trailer that this is where the
black widows get a lot of their orders
from I feel like the trailer makes it
pretty clear if you were confused before
but there are many black widows they're
all called black widows the reason why
we call Natasha black widow is just
because she's the primary version of the
character in the comics we see her in
her white uniform from the comics she
gets a bunch of black widow costume
changes during this she usually gets one
in each movie but within this movie
she'll wear a lot of different versions
of the ones that she had in the comics
this also seems like it's happening in
present-day too just because they're all
sitting around this table talking about
the good old days like look how fat you
got Russian Captain America talking
about taskmaster though I know people
have lots of questions people expecting
some big twist with his identity because
he never takes his helmet off it's kind
of like the Mandalorian never meant to
take his helmet off in the comics
taskmaster is a totally different person
I'm hoping that they keep him a
different person so that they can use
him in different ways in future movies
like a future Thunderbolts project but
he has the ability to learn people's
moves on the fly and improvise so he
could fight pretty much anybody he could
fight against Captain America he fights
Russian Captain America during the
trailer they just bum-rush each other so
that's going to be a badass fight talking
about david harbour's character make all
the stranger things season three jokes
that you want because he disappeared and
it was a plot involving russians but in
this he's playing alexei szostak off who
like I said is the Russian version of
Captain America you see him where his
classic uniform to this still fits so
clearly it looks like he's busting out
of a Russian prison here of some kind
just because of the way he looks it
doesn't seem like he's been kept in a
deep freeze like Winter Soldier is when
he's not on our missions but unless you
know how strong he is just seeing him
bust through this giant steel door even
though he gets kind of funny with it a
little silly later in the trailer when
he's making all those muscle moves you
see all of his Russian prison tats all
over him if you're not up on crime
thrillers or anything like that Russian
tattoos in prisons are a big deal
they're meant to tell the story of your
life so if you're in prison and you
don't have tattoos is actually really
weird we don't see him use it in the
trailer but he also does have a shield
just like Captain America made to look
like the red Russian star they start
talking about family echoing the things
that she said in the future in Avengers
endgame they said that this movie would
be a lot of her
during the read off of her ledger for
good so that when it came to Avengers
endgame that's why she was so ready to
make that sacrifice so her death in
Avengers endgame will make more sense
after you see the Black Widow movie when
Red Guardian and taskmaster go at it
this shield here is taskmaster shield it
looks a little bit different there are a
whole lot of shields flying around in
this movie
this is them literally trying to bring
down the Red Room metaphorically and
literally during this movie Yelena
Belova firing off a giant rocket
launcher this giant scene with her in
this version of the Black Widow uniform
might be happening in the past though
it's kind of hard to chart where some of
these big action set pieces are
happening obviously this is just a
fraction of the footage there's a lot of
scenes of her fighting taskmaster that
they did not put in this that they
showed up at d23 so that might be in the
next trailer but it's basically the
scene of taskmaster driving her car off
of this bridge then they start fighting
each other and you get to see how his
abilities work as he mimics her black
widow fighting style I'm sure you have a
ton of questions about what's going on
in present day because the present day
Marvel phase 4 films will take place in
2023 like Spider Man far from home takes
place after avengers endgame this is
just the first movie that takes place
before all that happens so I know
there's a lot of questions about whether
or not there's going to be scenes that
connected to present-day maybe through
the Yelena Belova Black Widow
character but post all your theories in
the comments below I'll do more Marvel
videos this week so if you have any big
bonus videos based on this Black Widow
footage you want me to do just let me
know in the comments congratulations
Thomas pitch you're the first Infinity
Saga giveaway winner please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details I've got a
second one to give away so I'll leave
that giveaway open for a while too while
you wait for everything click here for
my breakdown of the Spider Man into the spider-verse 2 teaser trailer
and click
here for my brand new Mandalorian Episode 4
video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!